good morning Ron how are you I'm doing
great do you want to start with your
match up with the A's and Yankees or is
there another matchup that you're
interested in where ever you want to go
I mean yeah but explain that though with
where Joe Maddon is like certain
managers are labeled you know good
clubhouse guys or you know their players
manager that kind of thing he's labeled
as a guy who doesn't handle this bullpen
very well so how do you get that label
and how do you overcome that label well
yeah I've known that I mean if you've
been around till now I mean it's hard
not the respect the kind of stuff he can
do and I think he's came changer as a
manager there's five probably
outstanding ones in baseball and he's on
that list you know with Tito Francona
and others but um you know I think what
ends up happening Dan especially in
yesterday's game when you see that the
pictures that show was bringing in you
know the inability of a stroke to be
ready because he's hurt
inability to have Brandon borrow who got
hurt early early in the season and Issa
we saw what he did with the Dodgers last
year in the NLCS you know he's a game
changer just you know no contact so I
think I think we can judge him on his
bullpen but I would say that his bullpen
is not as strong as it's been in the
past but I know he had some criticism
the way he is Chapman I always thought
he had Chapman for one postseason that
he was going to use as much a Chapman as
he could yeah
what you did so I think the criticism
listen it's all fair when it doesn't
work out but I think that you know their
bullpen is not as strongly sheriff it's
been in the past when you start to
handicap this trying to figure out and
you got a five game series you know you
get these one game playoffs then you got
a five game series in seven game series
do you look at these series differently
because of five best of five as opposed
to a best of seven once we get to those
matchups yeah I do I think you know
game number one in a game a five-game
series is just so important and so
important for the home team now that
being said I did
San Francisco only played Cincinnati in
2012 Cincinnati won both games in San
Francisco and San Francisco came back to
Cincinnati and won all three but that's
a rarity
I really think or if you take the Red
Sox series let's say you know the Red
Sox 107 games
108 games and we're unbelievable all
season long but the big test for them
will be their greatest starter in their
rotation how healthy is he so you will
know right off the bat in Game one
how healthy sale is is it a successful
season if the Yankees don't get past the
Oakland A's I would say no but they are
a team that I think in the beginning of
the year a lot of people might have
picked them over the Red Sox they did
have an amazing year 100 games but
coming into the season I think it was a
World Series or bust kind of year for
the Yankees so no I think if they lose
the wild-card will not be successful
they they went deep last season and I
think if they don't get into the
division series you'd have to call that
a down year for a Yankees franchise why
is it it feels like we're kind of
overlooking the Astros and I'm talking
about yeah in general here but it feels
like we're talking about the Red Sox
we're talking about the Yankees and then
all maybe the Astros love this that
alright that's fine you know took it you
know you forgot about us last year
forget about us again this year yeah
maybe the East Coast bias the one thing
I think that is amazing what the Astros
did is that with not a lot from Carlos
Correa the shortstop Springer was hurt
for some time during the year
Altuve did not have the season and was
hurt for a good part of the year we know
Alex Bregman became a star player now
but it really speaks to their depth that
they could have all of those players
Brian McCann was hurt and and not how
them in their lineup and still a set of
franchise record for wins I think it
speaks to not only their depth of their
team but it also speaks to what an
outstanding year their rotation had you
know two guys for Lander and Cole both
struck out over 250 batters five
pitchers with 10 or more wins I just
think they were as a team when I look at
even though they didn't win as many
games as Red Sox they was a team that
really night in and night out put a
picture out there that gave them a
chance to win most of the time so we
might be overlooking them because we're
not going to see them for a number days
but it's it's hard to overlook them once
they start playing again they just a
dynamite up and down that line of Korea
gets healthy
we had Orel Hershiser on last week and I
asked him you know when you're looking
at Clayton Kershaw and you know the
comparison sometimes with Sandy Koufax
and Orel Hershiser said he thinks
Clayton Kershaw is the best picture ever
I think Clayton Kershaw is one of the
best pitchers ever you know it's so hard
because you know now we're watching him
with a different point in his career I
mean a knock on Clayton if there ever
was is that in the postseason he has not
been as great as he in the regular
season well who is not many so I think
he's definitely on that list I'm not you
know one of those guys that says the
best ever because I think baseball has
so many different periods and
generations of the sport we've seen it
all from from dead ball era to steroids
it's really hard to judge when I think
of you know the greatest pitchers ever I
you know I think Clemens is on that list
I think Kershaw is on that list
I think Koufax despite you know the
limited career that he had because of
elbow injuries on that list is this
there's so many to me it's hard to
distinguish him from you know the
half-dozen
other great one because you look at
postseason success and you know somebody
like Curt Schilling was brilliant in the
postseason whitey Ford great John Smoltz
great Jack Morris was great like there's
certain guys that this the moment it
makes it kind of overshadows maybe what
they didn't do during the regular season
but if I said right you got one game to
win and you can hand the ball to anybody
who's that guy right now yeah I would
hand the ball to Justin Verlander I
think he is the John Smoltz of his
generation I think he not only gets it
done during the regular season but in
the postseason he takes it up another
notch we saw it last year and games they
had the win he was on the mound I just
think that what what he's done is it's
amazing to me because as we talked about
we just were talking about Clayton and
Clayton's you know his philosophies come
back to the pack a little I mean why
wouldn't it be with all the innings and
starts that he's had
but for that other than that small
stretch of about two and a half three
seasons where Verlander was a 500
pitcher and trying to figure it out you
know he has come back and unlike most
pitchers like CC Sabathia or someone
else you know have to regroup and reboot
your game he is at the same level he was
seized when he was an MVP and a nasai
young in 2011 so I think that's the most
impressive thing to me is that he's a
great pitcher during the regular season
great big you know big game pitcher and
he hasn't lost the thing on his ability
to dominate lineups that is remarkable
he's Ron darling Major League Baseball
on TBS analyst the wild card game on TBS
tomorrow to be the A's and the Yankees
but also trying to troubleshoot this or
figure out what is Hall of Fame worthy
here in the next 10 to 15 years with
pitchers because of the specialization
you know I look at you know you're
looking at Scherzer if you got three
songs are you gonna Hall of Famer Corey
Kluber with a couple of science are you
know like what is going to constitute a
Hall of Fame
career as a starting pitcher since you
might not have too many guys who are
getting 200 wins in their careers
yeah Dan you make a great point I think
that it's going to completely change I
think also you know with the younger
voting people that vote younger voters
you know analytics come into play I
think there's going to be a whole
entirely different change and then we
simply think about the SIA and the
National League this year you know
you're going to have a guy that won what
nine ten game games nine games 10 games
and Jacob degrom probably won it I think
we're at a confluence right now where
voters are coming off some of the
numbers that you and I grew up with
3,000 hits 500 old months 300 wins
automatics into Baseball Hall of Fame
that's going to completely change I
think winning percentage run prevention
those kind of things are going to be big
for starting pitchers moving forward
Awards of course like you said knack
sure sure I think with three songs is an
automatic yet
I don't care where he finishes the Korea
Kershaw less than 200 wins he
automatically goes in if he did not
pitch a game in 2019 and beyond so on
those magical kind of marks I think have
already been shut down with Pedro
Martinez getting in you know I think the
the the big huge win numbers the big
huge home run numbers those don't matter
as much as they'll you know the war and
and ER a plus and the ability to prevent
runs was there ever a guy that scared
you when he came to the plate when you
pitched no that's pretty funny yeah
there's one guy when I was pitching you
know you want to say that you never
really were afraid of anyone that came
in the box or whatever but Jack Clark in
his heyday and his viciousness of swing
I always say in today's game you know
Giancarlo Stanton who seems like he can
hit the ball you know those
when were repaired the shortstop jump
port and went over the fence that's what
Jack Clark was what like I mean because
of the viciousness of his swing he was
the only guy that I would throw a pitch
to and then I would lose the ball in his
swing so sometimes I wasn't you know if
he made contact I didn't know where it
was going off the back which is very
unusual and at times it scared the
bejesus out of me I thought he's the
truth and but he's the one guy in the
box he took up the whole box he was a
Paul Bunyan like and you know all he was
trying to do is hit a ball six hundred
feet off you and yeah so he's the guy
I'd hate to admit it but if I'm being
honest but I didn't like to see him come
to play could you could you tell by the
sound if it if you were giving up a home
run as soon as it left about yeah you
know yeah early in your career you know
you're you know you're such a rube
instead as soon as you throw it in there
the hitter makes great contact he kind
of know it's a home run but you're just
hoping with all hope that the ball stays
in the ballpark and after about my third
or fourth season I stopped looking
because as soon as I do the hitter had
hit it that I knew was out of the
ballpark so it's called for another ball
from the umpire but I had a no-hitter
seven six innings seven innings sorry
and but the last out in the sixth inning
in Philadelphia
I threw a pitch to Lance Parrish their
catcher and he had a ball straight over
my head and Gary Carter used to catch me
in those days whenever I would give up a
home run he would at the plate stand up
and then he would hang his head and look
down and and so as soon as he hit it
since I had a no-hitter going I looked
at a kid and he stood up and put his
head down I was like haha just ended the
no-hitter so I look behind me to see
what that ball was going because it was
going to be the first hit and Mookie
Wilson in centerfield caught it right
before the fence and kid looked at me
and he pointed like he I got you
I talked to Greg Maddux I said tell me
what the sound what's it sound like when
you give up a home run he said two cars
crashing you know I would say that it's
just the total opposite to me that when
I gave up home runs
it became eerily silent like the the
ball hitting the bat there's definitely
a sound of course but to me everything
went like matrix silent like whatever
reason as soon as I threw it and I knew
it wasn't a good pitch and I could see
the contact and the batter is gonna get
the ball out in front and you know all
that stuff you know that it's a bad
pitch it's gonna go a long way all that
it just became like silent for me I got
ten I got Jack Clark's pneumonia 995
three homers yeah well that sounds right
but you struck him out ten times though
as hitters and pitchers will tell you
you only remember you know kind of the
bad stuff you know the fear remember
anything no you know I faced I think the
two batters I faced to lost my career
Tim Raines and Ryan Sandberg and I think
I did well against them but I don't
remember doing well against them I
remember every single at that being you
know these guys were such game changers
so maybe because they were so good and
maybe because I faced them so well you
know they made me a better pitcher like
good to talk to you Ronnie have fun with
the A's and Yankees will be watching we
appreciate your time as always thanks
everything take care Ron darling for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you